my name is layla this is my impromptu ad
hoc ad lib talk now
um and uh we're gonna rock it well my
technical assistant gets my slides up
eventually you know you've made it when
you get an assistant
so my name's leila i'm a developer
advocate at vmware i'm a microsoft mvp
github star and i am the founder of
womenof.net lucy is a member of
womenof.net uh anyone can uh come and
support women in the womenof.net i'll be
there with her yay
um so you can always come and grab me
and talk to me about that i am usually
far more prepared than this but i've
been doing a lot of stuff virtually
maybe you know because of something um
so this is an azure functions a guide to
getting started um
who's used azure functions
okay
who's used v4
net six stuff okay well okay we have a
lone hand of that i decided
on monday that i was going to update my
really stable azure functions demo
to v4 and.net six don't don't do that
allow a lot more time two days was not
enough time i did get it working uh on
the other laptop um so we're going to
wing it we'll talk through code we may
not actually see live stuff flying
around because i haven't got everything
i need but like api keys but we'll be
all right it's fine
so i've already told you about that
that's me
now what are azure functions now they
allow you to develop more efficiently
with
functions
and it's an event-driven serverless
compute platform that can also solve
complex orchestration problems build and
debug locally without additional setup
deploy and operate at scale in the cloud
and integrate services using triggers
and bindings i mean that's quite a lot
to take on board
and you probably
need to see some stuff to help you bring
all that information together but what
they are effectively is something very
um small and lightweight that you can
quickly
get standing up so why functions perhaps
you have a big monolith
and it's a little bit old maybe it's on
framework
and you want to use some
latest
net features maybe something from cs10
or whatever version it happens to be on
and you have a unit of work that you can
take out so let's say a notification
system or something that's a processor
maybe it has highs and lows it's not in
constant use it's quite peaky it's a
very squeaky floorboard let me come over
here
so it's something that maybe you can
scale up really quickly uh so anything
that does processing
sending emails or
text messages or processing files is a
really good thing to abstract away and
put into an azure function and as long
as your actual application can go ahead
and and make an http call you're kind of
there
so that's kind of what i think
azure functions should be useful they're
like satellites around your your own
code they can be used in a microservices
architecture in that distributed
architecture you can build them out in
that way
so they are pretty versatile on how you
can use them
so how do they work
so what happens let's take the http
trigger there are lots of different
triggers we'll have a look at those in a
moment uh so you'll have an http request
come in
and that comes into the azure world
and that comes and says hey i i've got a
net azure function that i want to run
please and so azure goes and all right
i've got a server over here why don't
you go and and use that server and then
that server is like oh what what what do
you want um well i'd like functions
runtime please so it then has to start
that up
and then eventually your code will get
executed
and that's known as a cold start and i
think it can be like seven seconds i've
heard things of like 22 seconds as well
for that to come in
so that wasn't
super desirable really i mean if you
want a quick response don't don't go
down this route but
um the folks over at azure were like
well this isn't great so um
we um i'll go back here
they changed this a little bit to have a
warm start
so basically they already had
pre-allocated servers this is how it
works now that have
the run times on it so you've cut that
time considerably your request comes in
it's like oh okay throws your code your
function which is kept in blob storage
and it throws it up onto a server that's
already hot to trot
so we've cut that time down considerably
and that's a warm start
there is a hot start function um which
is when you deploy it onto your own app
service that's then like a web
application if you've got a web
application you can throw your functions
in there if you're already paying for it
you've already got that compute there
you can throw your functions in there
and you'll have them hot they'll always
be ready so that's a thought
two flavors because they don't really do
this cold start anymore because it's
just not not great
so visual studio and ryder come with the
um azure functions built in
so you can go right click new project
and get a functions app on there
you can use the azure function cli tools
which i was going to show you but we
don't have those on this machine
so you can use that with vs code if
you're running it so there's a whole
separate thing so normally on the cli
you have like net new
you need to have the azure function cli
tool so you would go like
funk to func and you would create a new
azure functions from there so it's not
dot net new it's funk init if you were
going to create a new project from the
cli
you do need a storage emulator to run it
locally now you may have
a storage emulator on your
machine that came with visual studio
but the uh that one is more or less not
to be used anymore and the thing to use
is azurite
so
that's what you will be using on
things other than windows as well it
works on windows so it is a
cross-platform
storage emulator and you can start that
up from your
cli and it will just give you a whole
load of endpoints for mapping for your
different storage
okay so the core tools i've probably
covered this uh but they allow you to
develop and test functions on your local
computer which is really important
because azure functions v1 was
completely in the portal that was
hellish to debug i i was right there
from the beginning going in there trying
to debug these it had all weird sort of
things going on you had this weird
light way of bringing in your
dependencies it wasn't a great
experience so with v2 you could develop
locally which is great because you have
source control and collaboration and all
of that cool stuff that you have with
your normal uh development like workflow
so they allow you to do that locally you
can connect to azure services and you
can debug them yay we love being able to
debug without having to hook a debugger
into the cloud
um and then you can deploy your function
app to azure
okay so this is where i would go into
code but let's let's see if we can we
can magic up some code
um i'm not going to show you this one
this you have really tiny fonts i'm
going to have my name
so let's open um
let's create a new
um
so let's go a new project
and
um
i'm gonna see if i can find all right
on the left
oh it's the opposite way okay
cloud general thank you thank you there
we go okay
um so let's just call this demo one i'm
hoping this is going to put it somewhere
that we want and right here um you can
see if i use this laser pointer um we
have all the different triggers
so you see we've got service bus http
timelifeq blog event grid we've got some
more down there we've got um
iot
like durable functions i'm i won't cover
that today but i'll tell you about those
sendgrid and all these sorts of things
see these are ready to go you can
connect into those and the codes are
already kind of written for you so we're
going to do a demo first with
http trigger
i'm losing my voice
so let's go and grab that and create it
and
and stick it there at least if it's
wrong it's wrong
okay so what we have
is it's already more or less written for
you so it's a great way to go and learn
with functions is just go and create a
new one
um so there's some interesting things to
do here you'll notice that there's not
really a
project for a program file when you
start we've got this
host.json
and this will say what version you're
using and and things like that and then
we have this local
settings.json
which not much in there and then you'll
you'll see there's a get ignore and it's
uncommon to get a good ignore with a
template um and that's because if we
look in here it has this line
so just know that um when you can
make it bigger bigger there we go that's
better for you and the back
so we've got this local settings.json
and that's because
azure functions are really heavily
convention based
so they come and look when you run them
locally in this file in this values
folder specifically for connection
strings and the things that they need so
they're being very kind the people who
write the template and not letting you
commit your uh secrets by putting that
in the git gnaw so just know that that's
there and and so it's good practice to
have like
demo.settings.json so you have the uh
architecture of your
settings in your source code not your
actual secret so we've got that here and
um
we've got
just a uh it's going to use local
storage so hopefully we've got local
storage on here loose
it probably came with visual studio will
bossy we'll see
um so let's go and have a look at the
actual function itself
uh let me unpin you oh key date key
so what we can see straight away
is that
it looks very similar to a method you'd
write in a controller
and this is your function name this is
what you will call
so this can be anything that you want
and then this is your methods here we've
got an http trigger function
you can set the authorization level when
you're developing locally it's always
going to be anonymous but when you
deploy it will listen to what this is
this one currently takes gets and posts
and then you can specify
a
route which is null in this case it's
going to use the default route
and then we pass through an http request
so it's kind of laid it all out for you
and then if we go here
it then tells you how to get stuff out
of your request
so if it was a get it's going to get it
from the query string so we'll get name
and if it's from the body it's going to
read out the body there and then it will
print some stuff so let's see if we can
actually get this to run
looks like it might be going
yes okay
so i don't know can i make this yes i
can make this bigger hurrah
okay so let me grab that pull this up
so what you get is it will print your
functions
out for you if there http trigger so
right now we can see it's got your
function called demo1 it's a get and a
post and then you've got 7071 is the
default uh
port for functions and then api demo one
that's your default route so it gives
you that if you had other types of
triggers it's going to pop those in
there as well and it will show you but
you you can't pull
a blob trigger for example
okay so let me grab this
okay
and then let's go and
see if we can
do
that
and we can go to it
okay
so you can see straight away that it's
just gone the default route on there but
if we go and add something to the query
string name
layla
you can see it's pick that up out the
string if i was using something like
postman i could do a body post there and
you can see how it picks out so if you
haven't done functions it's a really
good start just go in and play um and
and
and see what you can figure out so let's
go back here
right
ah
but i'm not the biggest fan of just
going hello world and and sending you on
your way um
so i want to
talk to you about
something that's more than just a quick
demo like i've shown you an actual
system that you could
implement and how you might want to do
it
so i have a transcription service uh
speech to text is actually quite slow if
you have a nine minute audio file it
takes about three minutes to transcribe
it if the service isn't busy so you want
to make sure
that you've got something that can deal
with a lot of load coming through and
passes it off appropriately so we have
this this system and we've got any old
app can take that recording in
and then we can upload an audio file and
that's on an upload function
and that function will just take that
streamed data
and then
save it
um and it's saving it to blob storage
now what we have is an a
blob trigger and the blob trigger is
another type of function that's
listening to a particular uh blob
container to be updated and you will
give it it'll match on the file name
that you use and it will go and and when
that new blob
item comes in it will do whatever you
have specified to do with it
and in this case it's going to
send off a
request to a speech to text api and it's
also going to update table storage it's
going to create a row in there
and then finally the there's one more
function which is another http trigger
which i use as a web hook and the speech
to text api calls that web hook when
it's done and ready um and then we go
and get the stuff and write it to the
table storage so that's kind of the
system and that's a very real world type
of system if you had an audio processor
say you want to resize images or you
want to do stuff with them like apply
filters it would be a system like this
you'd probably send them to
is it cloudnary that does all that type
of thing
okay
so let's go and have a look at some code
now
this sadly because i don't have my
actual laptop isn't going to
be able to run because i need
api keys and ports
to open and i need to find visual studio
again there we go
so let me is there another instance of
that
yeah and
there we go okay
but we may be able to do a little bit
with this one
so let me open it up and we can have a
little look here
all right so it's got quite a few
projects here this happens to be a
blazer one um i say i updated it over
the last few days to net six
um and we've got a few components
and then we've got a blazer server
application
so what i'm going to do is get that
running
is this only for github this term not
least
no okay
okay so let me just see where we are so
we're going to cd into the audio
spike
blazer
and we'll just do a net run on that
and get that going
corporate laptop security
okay okay all right
so um
we've got that one i've now got like a
gajillion of these open let me uh go
back here go back up
and then i'm probably going to run the
other one from here the audio processor
let's have a look so this is the one i
just described and we have this one does
look a little bit different because
you'll notice it's got a startup
so let's go in here
and this is quite um
an important point because
this actually
has dependencies
so you can use your dependency injection
and the style of architecture that you
might use on any old web app right here
in your azure functions
so
we've got that so we can use a startup
now the way you can get a startup to
come in is you have to do a little bit
of decorating we've got this here that
goes outside the namespace and you're
telling it to have a function start up
here and then it needs to inherit from
function startup which inherits from i
believe web jobs i have no function keys
so i don't know how to go in there but
it's fine um say
it's fine oh function there we go okay
gotcha
all right so you can see that comes from
iweb jobs um and uh wraps that so it's
all in there now
now i've done it how do i go
back uh there we go i've got it i've got
it
um
alrighty so let me close that one
so we've added
dependencies in here um i've got user
secrets that i could use um so we're
strongly uh binding those using the
options pattern that come in
so we'll have strongly typed
configuration to use within the
application i've got http clients um
i've got
uh
table db context these can be singletons
because they're apis they're not using
entity framework and things like that
and then various things to help with all
of the
transcription and writing to things down
here
and then we have the configure app
configuration settings down here like
you would on another application
and
we're telling it to use uh
user secrets ad environment variables
local settings things that you want
locally so that you can actually bring
in and bind those things
alrighty so come back in here
um
the the data up here is it's just
structured like any application and i
will warn you with updating
um things like table storage up they've
switched all the uh apis and the new get
packages deprecated a lot so again be
careful with those it's quite an
interesting thing to have done an
upgrade through this because the the
whole point is that they microsoft give
good migration paths to this but they're
very much uh just about like how to
update your
project
cs proj basically
not about all the triggers that change
so the blob trigger changed
and i'll show you how that changed in a
moment as well
so the first thing we have is our upload
function
and
if i come down here
we have um just like we saw before i've
let this one do a get and a post it
really only needs to be a post
and this is going to stream in some
audio
so it lets it come in
and then does some
some binding
and saves that off to blob storage and
that's all this does and that's really
important you don't want any long
running processes on a function because
they time out after i think it's like 12
or 15 minutes so you don't want anything
that's going to take too long
going on there so you need things that
are done and then moved on that's why
you have multiple functions
so that one will take the upload
and then back in here the next one we
have is the blob trigger
so you can see here i have a constructor
cons
constructor injection for my dependency
injection
just as you would in your regular
applications
so we bring in all the things that we
need and this is where it gets a little
bit different from the http trigger so
the the other types of triggers are
heavily convention based so you will
need to go to the documentation and see
what the conventions are
uh for your application so the thing
that we have here first is the path
to
the blob storage
so i'm going to look for new
blobs that have gone into audio
container and that have this file path
they match this so uploads audio and
then some kind of id in this case it's
going to be a good
and then i tell it there's a stream i'm
going to get this id which is the good
id which it gets out of the file here
and then i have a logo now one of the
problems when i upgraded so those of you
who haven't used v4 used to be able to
specify your connection string in here
and that connection string is in local
settings
um so you could specify connection
equals whatever the key name for your
string was that's all changed it has to
be called connection
so um i don't have a local settings in
here but i have a demo settings
so
whereas before it could be storage
connection string i haven't updated this
but
everything for your triggers
like
your blob storage has to be in this
values object it also can't be in user
secrets last time i checked so this
would have to be connection
it has to have that name now there's no
way that i have seen in the
documentation where you can specify that
how you used to
so these ones do actually have to have
your actual connection string in here
you can have other things down here
which will bind to user secrets
so those can all be down there so that's
a big difference it's very heavily
convention based that it won't run
unless you see
you've got that there
i mean it will run but you'll get an
error
okay so if we go back to that blob
trigger
so
we
have set
the thing that it's going to be
listening to
we've got that and then we come down
here we're getting some things out we're
reconstituting the file name we've got
the id in there
and then we've constructed an audio url
based on
what the path to the external path to
our blob storages so things that you
would have to do is make sure that the
permissions on your blob storage are
adequate if they're locked and
they're not externally accessible the
speech to text isn't going to be able to
go in and grab it
um so we built that and then what we
have down here
is a lot of logging because it's useful
and then we
try and upload the audio sample off to
the speech-to-text api
so this does that and down here you can
see it goes off to a service to do it
and then we also save the audio details
to table storage
so that's kind of the whole thing that
that bit of the function does so again
it's not long running it fires off an
api request
to your speech to text service and it
goes in
updates table storage so you can see
it's quite snappy when it does that and
then that's it it that's all that one
does
so then if we look at the final one
which is our
download function so this is the web
hook
so if i scroll down here
we have um
we've given this path
to the api function and when it's ready
it's going to call this and this is
another nice thing to have as an azure
function you have a um
a web hook because they're not always
called they don't need to be alive all
the time you can have that external
service call it when it's ready
so we do that and then this goes in and
says okay you're ready and then it will
go and make an api call and fetch the
actual
uh
speech to text transcription so that's
kind of what that whole solution does
now it's
it's not going to run because i don't
have the api keys
um but what that we would have seen if i
can go and explain
we would have seen that request come in
it would have fired off that download
the upload function that would have gone
then the application would have gone
quiet
we would then see a few moments later
the blob trigger would have fired off so
you can see that really nice
asynchronous workflow the blob trigger
would have gone it would have done its
little bit of work and then the whole
application goes quiet followed finally
by the download one which would have got
that request coming in
from the
um
third-party api and then that file so
you can see it's very discreet units of
work
which makes
for a really
nice efficient cheap way of doing things
so apologies that we can't see that
actually running
i just need to find
there we go
okay so let me start this again
um so we've got that there you could see
how that was kind of architected in a
traditional manner
so what do you need to think about when
you are structuring these applications
well
they can be structured like any dotnet
web application you don't have to learn
anything new you can just build them
like you would you can structure them
with multiple projects external
references and things like that and
build it how you would normally do so
there's no new learnings there really
supports.net cause dependency injection
which is a nice workflow i do get asked
about why you would have dependency
injection
in functions because they're spooling up
and shutting down there is a lot of
debate around that um but the time
difference for
creating these dependencies is quite
small for the amount of
decoupling and code management it gives
you
uh sports.net six
um and uh just try to remember that
single responsibility trying to get your
functions to do small simple units of
work that's i can't stress how key that
is enough that you do these small little
units of work
so the money always interesting
functions are more or less free yay we
love free
uh you can use the consumption which is
pay as you go
it includes a monthly free grant of one
million requests a whole million i mean
if you're doing some kind of fun project
or some small scale thing that's that's
a lot of requests
um
and then you get a 400 000
gigabytes of um
data processing through it and then it's
16p it's gone up it used to be 15p per 1
million executions
so
they are hugely efficiently cheap they
are so cheap so unbelievably cheap it's
great we like cheap when you think about
a web app i think a basic web app if you
let's not talk about throwing visual
studio uh in
sql server into that it's going to be
costing you like 35 pounds a month
easily that's probably more
so you can have that and
you know all that sort of benefits
without all of the cost overhead um a
nice demo actually is if you are
interested in um azure static web apps
and things like that and built with
blazer wasn't
one of the learn uh tutorials on the
microsoft learn platform is building an
azure static web app so you use blazer
wasm in the front but all of your apis
are built in azure functions because
they're so cheap
they're free
so you can go and play with them and do
things and if you've got personal
projects they they're not going to cost
you anything
so they are great to go and play and
then if you are using them for business
they're going to be really cheap really
cheap if you've got millions and
millions of things going through they're
still really cheap
now
the consumption plan is on that warm
start so where it's a little bit delayed
if you really really really need instant
response you can go for premium
so it offers the same features and
scaling mechanism now i should i didn't
talk to you about scaling consumption
plan auto scales i think it's something
like 200 instances it will scale to
completely on its own
um and then azure functions premium will
scale to i think 150.
you'll pay for it um
so it does use that same auto scaling
yes you can limit how much it scales to
you can control all of that um
with some caveats it doesn't have the
cold start because it's always alive
which is why you pay for it
and it does have some enhanced
performance
so it's built based on the virtual cpu
and memory that your function consumes
but you're going to have a baseline
there so it's going to cost you i think
around the same as a web app possibly a
little bit less but you're looking maybe
around 25 to 30 as a base as opposed to
free
um
so
the third option which i mentioned is
that you can put it into an existing web
app you can deploy it with your solution
as a yes another project and within your
solution so you can do it that way if
you've already got a web app and utilize
that compute that you're already paying
for
so we spoke
very briefly about security and
authorization
so if you remember in the code we had uh
if i go back
we had
on any of these
uh this authorization level
so all the functions come with that
um and then if we go back to
oh i maximized it whoopsies
you come back in here
we can see that we've got these five
types anonymous
anybody can come and get into your your
app
function means that it's based on the
per function that's localized to that
function
admin is admin only which i think is set
up within
the azure portal
system means anything within that system
and then user so there's various
different points in there um
there is something that came out last
year where functions all in the same
ecosystem automatically contract to each
other they don't need uh they're not
isolated they're considered inside the
same little
room and there's freedom of speech
through it so you there is some um
different security within there like
internal behind
the the wall
but
i am going to put a big butt here
do not rely
on these authorization keys please don't
use those as your only security unless
your api really does nothing much of any
import um as in a security point um
obviously what you're going to write is
important but
if it's something that is
sensitive please don't rely on these
keys okay
you need to secure your http endpoints
properly
so you can enable app service
authentication and authorization so
quite uh heavy you can use
azure api management
to authenticate requests say
and you can deploy your function app in
isolation so that protects it from its
its friends and then you can have a
gateway in front
so the app service authentication is
going to be like azure ids things like
that and
any kind of
authentication like um oauth and things
like that so you you basically
allow access through that
and then the azure api management
if you are using your apis in a business
manner so you're selling them on
and you have
that's your your main bread and butter
for earning money then you may want to
think about the azure api management
it's very expensive
i think when i last checked it's about
fifteen hundred dollars a month
so it's really pricey uh but say you
you have things behind there that you
really want to keep nice and safe and
secure that's gonna manage it it's also
gonna
do all the things that you might need
for your api management
such as rate limiting and
user authorization so if you having
different tiers of subscription perhaps
to the service that management
is going to do all of that for you so it
has a lot going on in that if your
business is api
management or api reselling
but it's very pricey so you can get away
with
a lot cheaper uh using uh just app
service authentication there are um
tutorials on how to do that um and the
the identity team at microsoft christos
matscas he'll always help you he's
helped me with how to do that kind of
thing
so
last year
we were given something called an
isolated process
this was so that you could run your
applications your functions using.net
five
so we've got two things the functions
run in process or they run the outer
process
everything but c sharp runs out of
process okay
so they
enabled um c-sharp to run out of process
as an isolated process
and that allowed you to use dot net five
in the latest features so what it it
does is it gives you full control over
the language worker startup so you can
have a program in there um and it allows
you to configure more features now you
can see that we have had dependency
injection in the applications that are
in process this just gives you more so
you get a program file you have more
control over the startup and things like
that
um and then with net six
you can now run in and out of process so
you can choose which way suits you
in preview now as well free preview so
you can go and play with this for free
is functions on kubernetes
so if you want if you have a
pre-provisioned cluster
that's not free
that's very not free
um you can uh stick your azure functions
on that i haven't played about that but
that only found out about that on monday
but i think that's pretty cool you can
run azure functions in docker containers
as well i think my next slide is going
to show you all the places that you can
deploy that so we've got the consumption
premium app service and then the new
things that i'm going to tell you
kubernetes
azure stack so that's your azure
on-premise
and then iot edge i haven't looked into
the iot i'm not quite sure what that is
going to look like but it is a
possibility so you can have these super
lightweight functions on any of these
things
so v4 which came out um
last november well g8 last november it
has the in process and isolated process
and it also supports node python java
powershell and then custom handler so
you can do some other sort of things
with it i hear the powershell ones are
really popular as well so if any of
those things um float your boat and you
want to play with them you can do that
with azure functions
and they can all talk to each other and
do things so it's very cool
so if you want some further reading um i
would say go check out the documentation
i will give you a link to these slides
so you don't have to take a photo of
this
um configuration um is quite uh an
interesting uh thing that one might be a
bit out of date now um that blog because
all the configuration is changing a
little bit
if you want to see actual um
like charts of the different speeds with
cold starts because lots of people the
things they say to me wow they're cold
starts they take too long to start it's
really not that big a deal i i urge you
not to let that stop you
using um
azure functions the the cold start
really isn't that big of a deal when you
go and look at it on this um
blog site and you see the charts there
you can see that it's not really a
problem
and then
there are a whole host
of really interesting blog articles and
how to's um on the latest features on
the tech community blog at microsoft and
i found a whole load of things and
there's loads of news and updates on
there and that you can go in and have a
look at so i i think that was pretty
cool for things like that as well as
general um blogs on them
um
and then
that's it i would have taken a bit
longer if i'd gone through my whole demo
and but we can have questions and we can
go back and look at anything
so
you can
get to my github repo which is um
layla hyphen p this is the the demo i
did was on there i have another one on
there that's slightly older and that's a
photo processor from the talk i did a
few years right here on this stage with
luce and we built a xamarin app live
here and i made an audio processor that
processed images so if that's something
that's interesting to you you can go and
have a look how the processor system
works for that very similar setup to
this audio processor that we have um
so but you can go and have a look at
that
um you can get all links to my stuff on
layla.dev and again women of dot dot net
if you are interested in that so we have
time for questions and we can go through
and i will do my best to answer them uh
so yeah does anyone have any questions
yes
yes so it's the functions runtime so is
that what you mean
oh sorry sorry
i really struggle with hearing in rooms
like this so please excuse me
um
yes so um i believe they will run for 15
minutes max i think that's off the top
of my head it could be 30 i'm doubting
myself now but there is okay so you do
not want these to do stuff i think the
max i would safely say uh you should do
is five minutes no more um because they
really
don't like it and then that's it they're
very
lacking in state
so really try and keep things think
about how you architect systems to do
one thing
and then let something else pick it up
when it's ready i think that's what i've
tried to show with that audio processor
is how you don't want to be hanging
around waiting for responses nothing you
do with functions should be waiting on a
response from something because they
just won't be around
did you have one
oh there's someone behind you steve then
you can go
okay right steve go
um when you did the new default template
yes it's using
this is a whole nother thing thank you
for pointing that out that's a really
valid thing
so as your functions
don't work with
system.txt.json okay
it this this stumped me for a long time
if we go back and look at this code
it's a really good question because
these sorts of you know when i say
they're heavily convention based
they are
now in these models and i have this web
hook response oh that's another point
that i can point out and let me just
show you where this comes in
if you look at
um the other triggers you remember they
had an i http request here you can write
custom models and they will bind to
those okay so that's a really cool
feature of them um but
if you are writing custom
dtos or view models for this to come in
when you go to them
and you maybe want to put some
decorators on them i had the
system.text.json decorators on here and
i was like why is this not binding why
is everything blowing up they are
written for newtonsoft you can use
system.txt.json to do your serializing
and deserializing but if you are looking
at decorators that the binding and the
internals of your application are going
to use you have to use newtonsoft.json
okay so it's yet another they're very
very very very
very opinionated okay that is all you
need to bear in mind when you're using
azure functions they are so opinionated
and so convention based right
so
yeah so you can either use the local
emulator or you can connect directly to
azure so this actual demo would have
used my
azure blob storage connection strings
live and ready to go um and so the app
would have been talking there and i use
to test locally i use ngrok to open up a
port into um
the computer so if you feel comfortable
using n grockets or tunneling um app so
not everyone is comfortable with opening
up tunnels through your firewall but um
if you wanted to test
the whole system locally you can use
something like engrock to do that um
that's for like the web hook coming in
um but yeah you don't need that if you
want to connect
for your app to talk to your live azure
blob storage or table storage and things
um but equally so you can run them on
azure right
um and and they'll be there so um at
least you might actually have azure
right because it comes with visual
studio i think
let's see
which is why
living very light
so
uh
lots of things i can do with lucy's
laptop let's not talk about that
okay
[Laughter]
it's not the first time i've had to um
present with someone else's laptop my i
remember i was in new york and i was
just about to go on stage and my
computer said ah no no i have to do my
update now and you cannot delay this
so it's not not the first time so um
it's one of those facts of lives so uh
if we have a look at azurite
it's going to tell me about a rock so
let's go microsoft
so
i just wanted to see if it's going to
have a nice picture
to show you
so if i go and look at the visual studio
okay um i think if you've used um
there's like a data explorer for um
like a lightweight data explorer that
you can use instead of sql management
manager studio a sql management
studio because you can't that's a
windows only thing so if you are
developing on a mac you can't use sql
server management studio so there's a
data studio that you can download and
they look like visual studio code so
azurite again looks very much like that
so you have um
like this nice gui to
look at
but you can also run it straight off the
command line and
it will give you all of these uh http
endpoints if i go down is it going to
show yeah so i'll show you like what's
your blog post and it'll give you the
it will say localhost and then it will
give you a port and things like that
so it's it will give you a lot of um
you've got cues in there so you can
do your cues and table
so you can do all of that locally really
nicely so i think it's a really good
system for that
any other questions yes
can you
trigger the same function using multiple
different triggers
yes
so um
you can have so different functions
calling the same
so they are
bound to be a particular um trigger if
you needed that you could encapsulate
your code
and have a blob trigger and a http
trigger that call the same method that's
how i would suggest doing that if that's
what you needed to do
but you can't have them combined you
can't have like a run method that has a
decorator for a blob trigger and a
decorative for http trigger they need to
be separate functions
to give them their endpoints
but the code the governs of that you
could
extract out and use
if i show you
durable functions
as well if we come here
if there's usually a nice diagram
now durable functions i always get asked
about these i've never bothered to play
with them because they are really
expensive um and i'm in this to play
with uh
like free stuff and the things i've
heard is that
and what i see from the architecture i'm
going to show you them because i want
you to see
is that
durable functions yes they are an
orchestrator but the the out of the box
azure functions
can do a lot of that if you architect
them well and i don't think durable
functions are really worth that i i read
an article about a company that switched
from durable functions to
regular functions they just
re-architected them slightly and they
saved themselves like sixty thousand
dollars in month
something ridiculous um
so i think you really need to know that
you need durable functions
and durable functions work in several
different patterns i'm just going to
show you the pictures because i'll give
you uh an idea so you can see process to
process to process
and then
you know some of these things are more
complicated and this is why you might
need an orchestrator such as the durable
functions but really think about can you
do it another way uh so you can see that
they do stuff and then fan out and we'll
call multiple triggers but could you
have a function there that does that for
you could you you have one that caused
those triggers and that's the way i
think about it
um
so you've got these other ones this is
kind of similar to what we had at
different ones talking to to different
um data storages
um if we go down here they can
chat to each other monitoring each other
human ones say there is one that will
ask for a human to go and do something
um and then i think is that it
um
aggregators
so you know there's quite a few things
there
that you can do
um
i i've just never seen anything that
i've really felt i need to step up to
durable functions for
the the regular functions if you
do them in a in a thoughtful logical way
you can get most of the way there
does that answer your question yeah
i know i went on a bit after it and did
more but yeah
uh any other questions
anyone inspired to go try them
oh good yay
there were a lot of hands there
go straight to v4 and dotnet
um don't don't do v3 just just don't
because
the upgrade is going to be horrible
um
and you can use all the lovely new shiny
features of dot net six and c sharp 10.
that's what we're on isn't it 10.
they're coming around so quick i can't
keep up anymore all right well thank you
very much if you think of any questions
you can hit me up on twitter nicely not
like her
and again my apologies for not giving
you the full beans demo um and a
thank you to luce
uh for being my savior and and giving me
a laptop so i could present that to you
so thank you very much enjoy uh the rest
of your day
[Applause]